[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
questions
thank you
[Music]
here
foreign
[Music]
thank you
pretty good
evening hello hello
welcome to the table
my name is Karen Miner and I'm so glad
you're here if you're new here
thank you like thanks for coming can
take a lot of courage to come in those
doors and for those of us that have been
here for a while it can also take a
little something to you know get in
these doors on such a gorgeous day so
good job everybody you're here uh I just
have a couple of announcements uh things
that are going on coming up and ways
that you can get connected here at the
table first of all uh we're heading into
May and that means Memorial Day weekend
is coming up
and Memorial Day weekend we will not be
having service that Sunday that is a
time for our leaders and volunteers to
rest connect with family a lot of people
go out of town on that weekend and here
at the table we like to have a couple of
Sundays during the year where we
incorporate a rest Rhythm that is
healthy it's good it's biblical and it's
good to rest so remember that we can do
that we can rest and then come back the
next Sunday and be together again so
just save the date Memorial Day weekend
we will not be meeting that Sunday
evening
secondly our meetups meetups at the
table are our small groups and they meet
throughout the week some of them meet on
weekends and it's a way to get to know
people here at the table outside of our
Sunday services so I want to highlight a
couple of those tonight we have a couple
of open groups meaning anybody is
welcome typically the open Group discuss
the sermon from the previous Sunday we
have one that is in Allen so if you're
anywhere near the Allen area we have a
meet up there led by Brandon and Caitlin
Randall it's a great group
and we have another group that meets in
the Wiley area so if you're around that
location we have a group that's led by
Miranda and Ramon Delgado that meets uh
during the week in the Wiley area so if
you're interested in either of those
groups you can come see me after service
and I'll tell you more information you
can also fill out a card on your way out
at the little table in the hallway
there's a box to check for meetups and
I'll email you with information about
what meetups we have whether you're
interested in those we also have other
ones that meet that you might be
interested in I would love to tell you
about those
all right how about if we take some time
just to arrive here be here press pause
on everything else that has filled your
day-to-day or the last week or the week
ahead and let's just arrive here now and
Center ourselves before we enter into
worship so if you could just close your
eyes
and whatever works for you whether it's
focusing on your breath listening to
your heartbeat
visualizing a place in nature that you
love
visualizing a person that you love just
something that helps
calm you
[Music]
laughter is good too
let's pray God thank you that we get to
be together tonight
thank you that you are here with us
thank you for those who are new those
who've been around for a while those who
are watching online God I pray that you
bless each and every one right where
they're at God help remind us that we
are all connected deeper than we could
ever realize
that we were we are all
connected by our Humanity our strengths
our weaknesses help us to have
compassion for one another God open our
eyes your presence and the ways that
you're working all around us
help us to tap into your hope and your
peace and your goodness
and God we thank you in Jesus name amen
amen thanks Karen
um real quick before we start I just
wanted to read a verse
um out of Matthew it's Matthew 11 and it
says come to me all you who are weary
and burdened and I will give you rest
take my yoke upon you and learn from me
for I'm gentle and humble in heart and
you'll find rest for your souls for my
yoke is easy and my burden is light and
we talk about burdens pretty regularly
here because following this next song
We'll have a section of our service
where we do prayers of the people where
we really want you to feel the space to
share the burdens that you're carrying
and allow us to kind of carry those
together acknowledge them make space for
those together
um
and I just was like getting thinking
this song really is referring a whole
lot to kind of that practice of sharing
sharing the heavy things together but
there's some things that are like a good
heavy you know like things that are
meaningful things that you're maybe like
using to push you towards growth towards
righteousness towards transformation
those can be heavy and that's okay when
we're opening ourselves up to like hard
truths that can do a good work in our
hearts and then there's sometimes that
um we're carrying things that were not
meant for us to carry the bad heavy the
heavy that God never intended for us the
heavy that's out of our control but we
are still grasping on with White
Knuckles the heavy that um leads us
further from truth further from who God
created us to be and this song is really
naming that we can let go of that we can
choose together to let that go let the
bad heavy go carry what you were
intended to heavy and give the rest of
it up surrender it so if you guys will
stand with me I love the song it's one
of my absolute favorites and I hope it
will be one that you guys will come to
love as well it's called what's heavy
behind so
noelle's Gonna Get Us started tonight
I mean what
[Music]
thank you
if you lost it alone
go and figure out why take a trip to
your dark side
go on and have a good cry cause
[Music]
[Applause]
I want to see your sadness I want to
share your sins I want to plead your
blood
I want to be lit in
don't you just
don't we all just wanna be together
[Music]
leave what's heavy
what's heavy behind
[Music]
[Applause]
if your face is down take a look around
do your fingers
[Music]
yeah
did you lose
sad because you did a bad thing hey
believe
he would tell me
who was Heavy behind
me
[Music]
behind
are you feeling fearful brother are you
feeling fearful sister
the only way to lose that fearful
feeling replace it with love that's
healing
are you feeling fearful brother are you
feeling fearful sisters
[Applause]
be
what's heavy
was Heavy behind
Lee was heavy
[Music]
what's heavy behind
Steve was heavy
thank you
what's heavy behind one more time
[Music]
what's heavy behind
all right kiddos y'all are dismissed to
go to your classes Anna and Devin are
taking the schoolers over here and we
have our younger kids in this classroom
right over here
um I just want to say another shout out
to our kids ministry workers I know Joe
is in the back at Nursery tonight Maggie
I think is helping out Chrissy thank you
guys so so much for all you do y'all are
amazing oh Becky sorry are you helping
tonight oh not tonight but sometimes she
is and they're helping so thank you
Becky
um appreciate you guys so much all right
we're gonna move into the prayers of
people prayers of the people
um so if you've been here before you
know what to do if this is your first
time
um we're gonna read this aloud together
and then we'll leave a space for you
guys to offer up um out loud things that
you're carrying that are heavy on your
heart tonight and we just want to
acknowledge those make room for them
like we talked about earlier and believe
that God is here in our midst and that
he is with us in the struggles
um so let's go ahead and read this aloud
for this city of Sachse Texas and for
every city and community and all who
live in them we pray to you for the Good
Earth you have given us and the wisdom
and the will to conserve it we pray to
you
for the old and the sick for the Widow
an orphan for the injured and suffering
we pray to you
for the poor and the oppressed the
unemployed and destitute for prisoners
and captives and all who remember and
care for them we pray to you
for the vulnerable the marginalized and
those unjustly targeted for their gender
sexuality race or other perceived
difference we pray to you for those
experiencing loss loneliness and
disconnection and for those struggling
with mental and emotional health we pray
to you
Lord we know that you love us and that
you hear us so we lift these names and
situations up to you
[Music]
for the names and moments that we have
spoken aloud and for those that we have
kept in our hearts we pray to you that
they may have life and light healing and
hope peace and a deep sense of your
presence
amen
[Music]
come and Tear Down the Walls I've built
up every wall I've built of every wall
I've built up cause you deserve every
piece of my heart every piece of my
heart every piece of my heart
I am
[Music]
faithful father and all that you have it
is
[Music]
like no other won't you come and break
through to me over and over and over
again I am bringing my heart to you with
open hands
closer and closer you're drawing me in
as the depths of my heart may be for you
again
over and over and over again I am
bringing my heart to you with open hands
closer and closer you're drawing me in
as the depths of my heart baby for you
again
Lord I am dressing that you are
is
you're a generous Giver your love's like
no other won't you come and break
through to me over and over and over
again I
[Music]
my heart to you with openness
tomorrow
[Music]
[Applause]
over and over and over again I am
bringing my heart to you with open hands
closer and closer you throwing me in as
the depths of my heart lay before you
again
come Tear Down the Walls
and everyone
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
that your spirit that your presence
guide your energy infuses us that it's
not some far off distant thing that
we're trying to arrive at God but that
it's something within us
but it's the life and the breath and the
blood within us where you have woven
yourself in
God would we sense you right now
that freedom
that kindness that forgiveness
that hope would it flood us God
[Music]
the burden
on my own yeah
[Music]
to let it all go yes
I'm done with the hiding the reasons
[Music]
thank you
so much
[Music]
that kind of love I don't understand
I can't comprehend all I know is
[Music]
the reasons
again
[Music]
my first breath running into your
oh
[Music]
deep in my chest your mercy is
again
[Music]
oh
again and again
we can come and approach you boldly it
says in Scripture that we don't have to
be afraid that we don't have to hide
from you but that we are your children
and we're loved and we're known and we
can come before you with boldness and
you will meet us with Grace
[Music]
thank you for seeing us thank you for
creating us and weaving us together God
and for the good work and the stories
that you're weaving together today in
this room
for the hope that you're wanting to
weave into our story God would we look
for it would we pursue it would we not
let up
would we believe that there is better
ahead
[Music]
would we lean into that transformation
lean into that good work that you do in
US
God we love the kind of God that you are
one who is near to the Brokenhearted
one who sees the Forgotten who's on the
side of the orphan and the Widow and the
suffering and the marginalized God would
we show up in that same kind of way
would we bring your light and your life
and your goodness not only into our own
lives but into the lives around us would
we be people who make a change just by
showing up
just by believing for more
[Music]
just by knowing that you are good and we
are loved and we are not alone
thank you for this time together thank
you for this community God keep leading
and guiding us
it's in your name we pray these things
thank you guys for worshiping with us if
y'all want to turn and greet the people
around you make them feel at home and
welcomed and then Brett will get us
started on our message
thank you
for grace and peace
so good to be with you all and my name
is Brett I'm the pastor here and it's
just it's a joy to be able to welcome
you uh to the table and that includes as
always those joining us online and uh
and anyone here who is new thank you for
for being Among Us
um you know I know depending on kind of
church backgrounds and things
coming into a church space it can just
be a lot
um you know there's there's even a thing
like of church trauma you know where
it's sort of like the body has certain
reactions even just into coming into a
space and seeing like the cross you know
and not because you don't like love
Jesus or like the cross you know but
it's it's just like oh my gosh I'm back
in that place you know and even if
you're like there's a part of your brain
that knows like no no this is different
this is different this place is safe
these people it's just different
um but it's like there's still parts of
you know that's like oh there's a yeah
so all that to say I hope I didn't just
add to your anxiety hopefully you feel
seen you're like I wasn't that nervous
till until you said all that
um but I I do hope um yeah just know
that you are you're loved you're
accepted um just right where you're at
and uh we're so so glad you had the
courage to to walk through those doors
oh that's a big deal and we don't take
it lightly so
um we are in uh week four in our series
titled Easter tide this is not the end I
know for you know most of us or many of
us we tend to think of Easter as like
well it's Easter Sunday you know that
one that one Sunday a few weeks back and
then we kind of move on with our lives
and uh for much of the broader Church
Easter is actually an entire season
which makes a lot of sense because you
have sort of lint this like 40-day time
of preparation leading up to like Good
Friday the day of the Cross and then
onto Easter Sunday and it would make
sense you'd have 40 days of preparation
and then not just a day to be like Yay
you know celebrate but you would have 40
days on the backside to like hey let's
Rejoice Christ has risen and uh and so
that's kind of What's um what we're
doing in this series is I'm really
seeing that you know Resurrection is not
the end of the story and it's not uh
hooray for Jesus but there's actually an
invitation for all of us in Easter so
that's kind of what we're pressing into
is seeing what kind of um faithfulness
uh what kind of love
Christ might call us too so with that in
mind the title of my message specific to
tonight is bound and loosed bound and
loosed and uh this is it's a very much
kind of you'll notice for if you were
here last Sunday you'll see it was like
a similar passage although um this is
still very much a standalone message so
if you weren't here that's fine you
won't be like lost or anything
um but just to kind of recap we're in
um basically this passage from John 20
which has a lot of kind of interesting
moments like you know we'll read in just
a moment where he like Jesus appears to
disciples but he walks through like
walls in a locked door uh and then we
had a message last week all about this
moment where Jesus breathes on the
disciples
which is kind of an interesting somewhat
strange you know thing to happen uh and
then we'll move on uh in just a moment
to something fresh and new but I want to
kind of recap where we were last Sunday
so kind of will read up to that point uh
again so John 20 verse 19.
on the evening of that first day of the
week when the disciples were together
with the doors locked for fear of the
Jewish leaders
Jesus came and stood among them and said
peace be with you
after he had said this he showed them
his hands and his side the disciples
were Overjoyed when they saw the Lord
again Jesus said peace be with you as
the father has sent me I am sending you
and with that he breathed on them and
said receive the holy spirit so last
week we talked all about that moment of
the breathing which again might strike
us as just like what is going on um but
we we talked about how in essence what
Christ is doing is
um not simply calling them to like an
outward external imitation of Jesus
where they try to do kind of a bad Jesus
impression
um but instead where he he gives them
the very spirit of God that filled him
he breathes it into them
so that in essence they begin to live
it's sort of like living from the inside
out
and uh so we all unpacked last week was
how it's the same for us it's not just
like oh good for the disciples but but
that same kind of breathing moment
happens for each of us where um God uh
kind of calls us uh and we begin to be
filled more and more and more with God
and with life and light in Christ in
love and
um and so we begin to kind of live in
the same way now
um
where I want to go is interesting though
the story doesn't end there so we'll
start again in verse 21 for again a
little context Jesus said peace be with
you as the father has sent me I'm
sending you with that he breathed on
them he said receive the Holy Spirit and
here's where it keeps going if you
forgive anyone's sins
their sins are forgiven if you do not
forgive them they're not forgiven
and then from there the story just moves
right on to another topic
and I don't know about you but I'm a
little stuck on verse 23.
um you know like why what that's the
that's the end nothing nothing else
Jesus no more words on that because I
think we'd appreciate a little uh
unpacking you know
um but he he doesn't really uh no he
doesn't it doesn't do that it's just um
in essence well I think one way to maybe
consider is
this very much
um I think flows from the context of
verse 21 which is why I had us read it
um twice
all right Jesus said as the father has
sent me
now I'm doing what
now I'm sending you I think it's one of
those you know it's interesting when we
read the Bible it's easy to just kind of
read it and you're kind of like okay
cool cool and just we just keep going
you know maybe even if you have like a
scripture reading practice or something
uh I I have this where I'll read you
know in the mornings with a cup of
coffee it's always a nice pairing and uh
but I'll notice at times like you've I'm
sure this happened to you where you're
reading but like your your eyes are
going over the words but you're like not
really tracking you know especially if
you're sort of familiar with it oh I've
read the gospel John before you know
it's like the mind is I don't know the
eyes are moving but the mind is you know
elsewhere I think that can kind of
happen you know even when sermons were
sort of like here's the scripture for
today like okay he's the pastor he reads
the Bible and we you know but it's like
wait wait wait wait wait back up
what is that talking as the father sent
Jesus
so we are now sent like in essence we
are now the body of Christ in the world
like that's one of those sort of
theological you know like truths that
were like oh yeah I'm the body of Christ
you know it's adorable you know but it's
like whoa this is like kind of a big
deal
um in other words the very mission
that the father gave to Jesus like now
we receive it and we carry it on now
which begs the question
um yeah and what was that that mission
uh exactly and I I think I'll start with
what it was not it was absolutely not
for Jesus himself to be like filled with
the spirit
and to be like wow I am so great
people will love me man I wish these
other people could have the spirit but
oh too bad for them uh clearly not right
this was not Jesus mode in the world
like instead what what you might say
that he he found himself interacting
um
with people
who life
and others
had crushed
had hurt
um had shamed
like people
um beat down run down in guilt
and and a deep feeling that I'm I'm kind
of separate I'm separated I'm um
alienated from
um from God from other people
from myself
and and Jesus entered into that kind of
world
and and what did he do
he spread light and healing and
forgiveness and Hope
everywhere he went can I get an amen
like that is who Jesus was that that was
the the heart of his mission
and and so it this this whole um passage
honestly it it merely brought to mind
another passage which is very rarely
preached on but it's it's another kind
of strange one
um and people interpret it in kind of
weird weird ways the the sister passage
is Matthew 16 19 where Jesus in a
different context different moment but
you'll kind of notice a certain
similarity there's kind of an as below
so above structure going on uh and he
says this I will give you the Keys of
the Kingdom of Heaven
whatever you bind on Earth
will be bound in heaven
whatever you loose on Earth
will be loosed in heaven I have a uh
kind of background in the charismatic
world so we love this verse even though
we were a little hazy on what it was
talking about but we were just like yes
whatever we bind you know is like very
even though it's sort of and what what
is that what are we doing you know that
was never really made clear but it was
something spiritual you know and I I
think I wonder if it's actually not like
just mysterious we have no ideas what
are the keys to the kingdom you know uh
what if it's not like some esoteric
teaching especially if you read it in
light of John chapter 20 verse 23. like
and maybe it's more than this but I
don't think it's less than something as
absolutely
um practical down to earth as
forgiveness
I mean Jesus moves through the world
and everywhere he goes right he's
encountering people who who you might
say
um
are just utterly bound up
so what does he do
he begins to set them
free
right if you forgive anyone's sins their
sins are forgiven if you do not forgive
them they're not in other words we might
sum it up by saying to be Unforgiven
is to be is to at least feel like we are
bound up
constricted choking have you ever been
there
unlike our own guilt and shame
are self-loathing
but to be forgiven what's that church to
be forgiven is a moment of losing
not of losing which I realize the typo
let me see is that in mind it's not an
okay uh of of losing
um in other words uh it's a moment right
it's a moment of freedom of freedom of
Freedom like this is who Christ was and
I think it's interesting it is easy to
to read you know the last part of that
verse that verse 23 about the whole if
you don't forgive they're not forgiven
and to be very weirded out and kind of
freaked out
um and I in ways I don't want to I think
it's probably like a whole other message
to kind of unpack that I will suffice to
say that a few months ago I appreciate a
message about how we are all much more
connected than we realize how we tend to
think of our even just our bodies as
like we are autonomous isolated just
people cut off you know there's me
there's you and we don't really like
unless we're like speaking or like even
a hug we don't really you know
um but in light of the kind of
mysterious nature of bodies in the New
Testament we even saw it in this passage
Jesus and his spiritual body walks
through the wall you know um I wonder if
we are like much more interconnected
than we realize
and I wonder if there is some sense in
which when we um move through the world
um in this mode where it's like no I'm
not forgiving like no that I I wonder
um I think ultimately it is in God's
hands but I don't know I wonder if
there's something
like if it has an effect at some level
um now on a more I'd say like positive
note
um remember the context I keep coming
back to the context verse 21 as the
father has sent me I am sending you and
and now I'm asking not so much what was
the mission of Jesus but like what was
the heart posture
the tone of Jesus as he moved through
the world like in other words who did
Jesus carve up the world into those he
was like okay
I'm forgiving you
but not you like just think of his life
and Mission if you've read the gospels
like find me the people that Jesus just
said you know what
um
I'm choosing to keep you bound up you
know like find me those people um I
think you'll have a lot of trouble
because like I mean just think of the
most I don't know extreme examples maybe
um there's these moments in the gospels
where Jesus encounters someone who is
demon-possessed is kind of consumed by
evil itself I mean if there's sort of
like a boundary case a boundary example
you're like well that is that's pretty
intense
you know
um what did Jesus do for those folks he
set them free
said you are loosed you are forgiven you
are made whole this is how Jesus moved
through the world
or maybe we say um what about the
disciples
you'll recall we just came through the
season of Lent and they at the cross
they like Jesus arrested and they all
what do they do
grun
how did Jesus interact with them we
actually just saw it in this passage he
walks through that wall
remember the first words on his lip lips
peace be with you
he sets them free
or I wonder about um Peter Peter who of
course you know denied Jesus three times
what does he do he forgives him
uh or Judas there's an extreme example
like what about Judas
the ultimate betrayer
how did Christ interact with him if
you'll recall Jesus knew exactly what
Judas was going to do do you remember
what he did right before Judas left the
room to go betray him at that last meal
remember what Jesus did
he served him communion
this is my body
broken for you Judas
this is my blood
shed even for you
friends
I don't think we need to be so freaked
out about that The Unforgiven thing
because it is pretty clear how Jesus
moved through the world and therefore
it's pretty clear how we are called
to move through the world
with a Grace
the patience
with a compassion that knows no bounds
because this is who Christ was we might
say it like this I'm never more like
Christ
that in the very moment I speak
forgiveness over another
because this is who Jesus was he came to
set people free
Church what a mind-boggling
vertigo inducing wondrous lofty calling
we have been given as the father has
sent Jesus
so you and I have been sent did you know
this is actually why we close the
service and most churches do this or I
should say many um it's kind of not as
popular now
um but we close the service not by
saying well
um thanks so much for being here uh you
can leave
uh we don't do that boy that would be
really awkward I made that really
awkward uh hey uh so I guess we're done
now that was even more um we don't do
that
wait don't do that uh instead you know
what it's called right there at the end
it's known as a benediction if we had a
program if we were church with programs
you would see it every week on your
little outline you know benediction and
what is it benediction um contrary to
what a lot of people think it's often
thought of as Like a Prayer
um but it's actually not you'll notice
the person who gets up here at the end
they don't say like Lord would you
protect all these people and you know
it's like they're not talking to God who
are they talking to
you
and and what is it a it's a reminder of
identity and urban addiction we repeat
over and over you are a child of God you
are a child of God filled with God's
holy spirit right I mean it's all John
20 kind of stuff
and then what happens after that then
you're not dismissed but you are what
sent
all right can you see it like you are
sent as the father has sent me Jesus
said now I am sending you and so every
week
we're called we are we are sent into the
world to move through it just as Christ
did and I think what um
you know I should I should say a word on
forgiveness I I know
um
for many of us I'll say in like kind of
um churches like more kind of
progressive churches
um forgiveness has really fallen on hard
times and at some level it is
um I deeply understand why
um there can be a tendency to kind of
like anything needs to be used with
discernment
and at times forgiveness has been sort
of like really pushed on people
you know um I think the classic example
is like someone maybe who's like
suffering abuse
and it could be like bad for the church
as whole or something you know so that
person sort of like pushed to forgive
like hey okay well it's been 72 hours so
you know are you ready to Forget You
know I mean like so let me just name you
know anything can be used and abused and
certainly forgiveness has
um however I'll just name my fear
is is that maybe we might swing that
pendulum
so far
that in essence we we lose the
um you might say the the art of learning
to relate
to one another
to our families even to strangers in in
just a heart posture
that Jesus did just one of of Grace and
and one that leans into forgiveness so
beautifully
um and I think this is what Jesus is
just modeling for us
so powerfully he just he teaches us the
right um headspace and heart space of
how to move through the world
um there's a former Archbishop of South
Africa Desmond Tutu a man who opposed
racial apartheid and Injustice in his
own country I think he did a wonderful
job of really walking both forgiveness
and Justice out at the same time
um
and I mean it was brilliant if you're
not familiar with him
um look him up I mean just an amazing
story
um but he had this quote he said this
forgiveness is truly the Grace by which
we enable another person to get up
and get up with dignity
to begin anew
I love that I love this for a few
reasons I love the language of getting
up it's really similar Can You Hear The
Binding leucine thing even though it's
just a different metaphor instead of
bound and loose it's on the ground sort
of under my heel and okay
get up right
um but also I love that language of to
begin anew
to begin anew
um you know when I think of
like what Christ was accused of
was in essence you can't go around
speaking of forgiveness over all of
these people right it was sort of the
the Sinners was the the language of the
Bible you know you get Jesus what are
you who do you think you are first off
you're forgiving you're just forgiving
sins as though your God himself you know
just kind of interesting moment and and
then you're just doing it like
frivolously far too frivolously how
these people ever change if they're not
shamed properly you know
um and this was the accusation kind of
put at him in slightly different words
but in essence that was sort of the
heart of it
um and but you can you can hear though
it was what was Jesus motivated by I
think just such love
such love he wanted people to begin Anew
to begin Anew to get up with dignity and
begin Anew I'll close
um with this I I recently came across an
author whose work I really appreciate
his name is Mark Vernon he's a former
Anglican priest in the Church of England
and then he became a psychotherapist
so now that's more what he does a lot of
therapy and um he said recently that he
he started to realize so clearly how um
he said All Therapy it begins in an
atmosphere of forgiveness
he said in essence people you know walk
through his door
and especially
um you know maybe when they're in a mode
not so much of like oh my gosh I've been
terribly victimized but in in more of a
perpetrator you know kind of like oh my
god I've done things I can't even
forgive myself you know those kind of
moments and he said he realized like in
essence they walked through that door
and even if he doesn't literally say it
the whole atmosphere is okay look look
everything
Is Forgiven
Everything Is Forgiven
now
can we start to have a conversation
about
how you got here
and how you might move forward
it seems to me
um that Mark Vernon and Jesus are very
much on the same page whereas it's easy
especially in religious circles to have
a tendency to say
when you get your life all figured out
when you transform when you change when
you earn it
Finn then I shall forgive you
but what does Jesus do with that just
flips it around
and suddenly the invitation is
let's start to lead
with an atmosphere a heart posture of
forgiveness
that then opens up the space
for God to begin to work in someone's
heart in mind lets them get up
and begin again get up with dignity and
begin a new in essence
um to speak over people you are loosed
you're loosed
so
church that's our that's our call and I
wonder what what could God do with a
community of people who who just leaned
into being a leucine kind of people a
losing kind of church a leucine family a
leucine um community
I think that could be powerful and
beautiful and in exactly
um so much of what our world needs
in the name of the Father the Son and
the Holy Spirit
amen
so as we transition into communion
as we come to the table of the lord it's
a moment
where we take in
Christ's body
in the bread and Christ's blood in the
wine
and we remember again
first off that we ourselves have been
loosed
Christ has set us free
and then as we talked about earlier we
are then sent
into the world
as the father sends Jesus
so we are sent
so I hope this can be a moment one of
the reasons I love communion each week
is it's a moment where everyone kind of
steps off to the side like no one's up
here you know saying more words it's
just you and Christ
and I hope it's a moment of Liberation
maybe you're in need of losing
maybe that's where you are tonight
Christ speaks that over you
and yeah I hope it's a just a powerful
moment between you and Christ so um
the way we'll do this is we'll kind of
start towards the front and folks will
just kind of form a line here to come
forward the red is wine and the white
cups filled with the kind of white yeah
that is uh grape juice
so don't get those confused we've had
people get those confused
um the bread is gluten free and we also
practice what's called an Open Table
meaning if you're here tonight and you
want to participate and connect with
Christ then you are free to do that uh
it's regardless of kind of your exact
like denomination or your theology and
whatever you know just know if you're
here tonight and you want to participate
you're welcome to do that having said
that there's no pressure or stigma if
you would rather not um that's perfectly
okay too
so this is the table
not of the church
but of the Lord
and it's made ready for those who love
him and for those who want to love him
more so come
[Music]
you who have much faith
and you who have little
[Music]
you who have been here often and you who
have not been here long
you who have tried to follow
and you who have failed
come
because it's the Lord Jesus himself who
invites you and it's his will that those
who want to meet him should meet him
here
come to the table
foreign
[Music]
thank you
really
if you guys want to stand with us as we
close out this last song
[Music]
thank you
God I look to you I won't be overwhelmed
give me Vision
to see things like you do God I look to
you
you let my help comes from
give me wisdom
you know just what to do
[Music]
I won't be overwhelmed
give me vision
see things like you do and God I look to
you
you where my help comes from
give me wisdom
to see things like you do and I will
love you Lord my strength
and I will
Love You Lord my shield
and I will love you
Lord my rock
forever all my days I will love you guys
[Music]
let's sing that again and God I look to
you
I won't be
overwhelmed give me vision
to see things like you do and that I
look to you
you're where my help comes from
your wisdom
you know just what to do and I will love
you
Lord my history
and I will love you
foreign
[Music]
Hallelujah
forever all my days
[Music]
Hallelujah
forever all my days
[Music]
thank you so much for being with us
tonight I hope that this service bless
you in some way uh and gave you just
something you needed tonight
um for those of you who are new we would
love to have a record that you were here
tonight if you could on your way out in
the hallway there's a little tiny table
with a box and some cards on it if you
could just take a minute and fill out
one of those cards for us drop it in the
Box uh we would love to be in contact
with you this week and just say thank
you for being here also if anybody here
is in need of prayer a listening ear a
hug anything please come find me after
service I would love to be there for you
and I just want you to know that you
have a place here you do you in all of
your fullness all of who you are you
have a place here
also don't forget our meetups that meet
throughout the week you can get more
information about that by coming to find
me or filling out one of the cards you
can check the box that says meetups put
that in the box and then we'll get in
touch with you this week with more
information about our meetups and then
the lastly as Brett mentioned we haven't
been addiction that we like to speak
over you and send you out with into your
week so whatever posture helps you to
receive that whether it's opening your
hands closing your eyes standing very
solid on the ground whatever that is for
you
let me speak this benediction over you
you are a child of God
[Music]
are a child of God
this is true on your best day
and it's especially true on your worst
day
so as you go into your week ahead with
its yet to be determined highs and lows
and everything in between
go with the assurance that you are loved
you are worthy and you are accepted Just
As You Are
and go filled with God's Holy Spirit and
the desire to extend these same Gifts of
love and grace and compassion and
forgiveness to everybody you come in
contact with
have a good week be blessed we hope to
see you back here next Sunday good night
[Music]
Lord my sheep and I will love you Lord
my
forever
[Music]
Lord my
Shields
[Music]